I made a comment about my self-worth and
I get this a lot about my self-worth
okay
sometimes you know but Usman has given
me a lot of self-worth I know you guys
don't see everything but
do you know what it's like to wake up
every single morning and look into your
at your social media and say how ugly I
am how desperate I am I'm gonna cry
sorry how delusional I am throw up
emojis I mean that disgraces me more in
my self-worth than anything who's been
has done so far I see everything okay I
see everything and I'm really good about
like now I just put my phone away or
like I know about hidden words and I
block I block all damn day good luck but
like my self-worth is really important
to me like right now at this moment at
52 I'm beautiful I look amazing I
probably look the best I've ever looked
right and using gives me that too it's
not I don't need him for my own
self-worth now my health work there's
nothing he can give you exactly exactly
but does that make sense like my
confidence and stuff like the things
that I get online which I was talking to
somebody the other day and I said they
said we don't know how you have had a
nervous breakdown yet because I get it
so bad and it's constant I mean constant
and it's just like no matter which way I
turn or what I do it's just that when I
recap your moments on the show I do
bring up self-worth or self-love and I
do it too and I I get real like I've
been in positions not as Extreme as
maybe but where I put myself aside just
to get someone or just to get them to
choose me you know not even thinking if
I'm liking them or what they're offering
me and for me that was a self-worth
issue so do these comments even though
they're hurtful do they cause you to
reflect and say well maybe there is some
like deeper soul-searching I should do
sometimes sometimes they do sometimes
most of the time I just try to ignore
you know but sometimes I'll read when
I'm like damn that one hit home you know
and it does and I do things different
now like I drew I self journal I you
know I do I read different like like
self-help books just for my own sanity
and my own sake especially since my mom
passed away you know so I deal with a
lot of I deal with a lot of
um just like things to make myself
better like I started going to the gym
and I said you know I started eating
better and I started and I noticed like
all of that helps me you know but I'm
grateful for the ones that I have really
good followers now I will say I have
really good and like if somebody makes a
bad comment there's 50 of them that are
just like don't talk to her like that
well what's crazy I was gonna bring this
up a little later but since she brought
it up it's a 90 day we love to see it
moment it Dixie had a really nice
comment that she wanted you to see she
said quote Kim you are a beautiful
intelligent woman you do not need to
wait she did get real you do not need to
put up with the disrespect you are
receiving take your beautiful self back
to the United States and find you a good
man that will treat you respect you and
love you as he should sending all my
love and prayers to you stay strong
beautiful oh tell her I said Thank you
thank you Dixie thank you so much I love
that name too why do I love that name so
much thank you Dixie I appreciate that
thank you so you definitely have love
out there
um yeah yeah yeah yeah all right so
let's go back to the second wife
situation Monique she made a good but
direct Point she says quote being the
first wife doesn't mean you're the most
loved or favorite do you still feel as
if that being the first wife will give
you that position of being the most
loved no I don't feel that way now I
feel that
um
we would be equal so and I'm fine with
that is it going to be easy just like I
said is it gonna be easier you don't
know it's not going to be easy it's
going to be a total mind blow when this
happens you know but I I feel I'm more
equipped to deal with it now than I was
last year yeah and don't sound so sad I
mean it's your decision I just
I don't want you to settle for something
that truly won't will make you happy
when you could there is potential for
you to have somebody that is only for
you you know it may take time and you
may have to wait it may take some
healing work whatever you have to do but
I just you know I understand I
understand where you're coming from and
I understand where people are coming
from I mean this is not normal it's not
it's not normal by any means here you
know but this is totally normal over
there and I've talked to a lot of these
friends and a lot of women over there
you know about the subject and and it's
just it's gave me it's given me a lot of
clarity that's why I'm so I'm okay so
you and Usman have discussed him moving
to America how are you sure that he's
not scamming you how what gives you
peace of mind when it comes to that
because I know him and I've spent time
with him I spent time with them many
times okay and I just I just know him
like I I know Easton and I know
everybody's really oh she's crazy here
she goes again you know oh she's
delusional but I know him and I know
who's been like nobody understands how
close Usman and I really are not
everything is like about him wanting to
come here he's got a really good life
there like he's he does really really
well there you know but I don't think
he's do I think he's gonna if I bring
him here he's gonna come here and just
like leave I just don't believe that or
if he's using I mean this is very Frank
and I hope it's not the case or he's
using you to get the green card no we're
too close for that I feel that that was
the case why would I go down there
privately
you know what I mean
yeah that's how I feel yeah I have a
dementia talk beautiful out 60 women
around me I'm rejecting it because I
feel like it shouldn't be beauty or
whatever it should be loved you
mentioned Usman helping you with your
self-worth as a viewer I don't know I
mean people edit things or whatever but
it it seems as if there have been more
attacks on your self-worth especially
when he tells you that he doesn't
see you as beautiful or he insinuates
that that it's not Beauty it's the love
or the Loyalty how does that make you
feel I told him that and I've said that
too I'm like why do you say it like that
because that's what I said it's not a
compliment I don't know it's not and
that's what I told him how would you
feel if I went on there and talked about
how skinny you are no you know like how
how I said how I feel about things
sometimes you know what I mean and I
told him I was like it's an insult to me
when you that's not what I meant I would
never but that's what you said though
that's what you said and I said you you
know do you know how that makes me feel
I was in a
mentally like mentally abusive
relationship before and it and it where
somebody was calling me ugly or somebody
was doing very manipulative you know and
I see that and then he makes these
comments and then and then when I watch
them I'm like what were you why did you
say that or when I'm in the you know
when it happens like when you said that
when I walked off the last time and
everything and I was like do you know
how much that hurts me like do you have
any idea like do you just it makes me
feel not beautiful you know
no I don't deserve it and then but then
when we're laying in bed or when we're
watching he's like you're so pretty
without makeup you're so this you're so
that so it makes me it's like
flip-flopper you know but that's but
that's what makes me very like oh
because I understand you gotta be
through and through you say one thing I
need to see it in your actions it needs
to be consistent but because you
flip-flop I hope you're gonna interview
him and I hope you ask him these same
questions I mean the last time I did I
was I was pretty hard I was I was
straightforward with Usman but I
actually that's a good point I should
look into interviewing him seriously you
and Jamal super close I admire your
relationship and I might have he's
gentle yet very honest with you
sometimes too honest he's like my dad
sometimes I swear okay
in a similar relationship to yours what
would be the number one piece of advice
you would give them
that is a good question just to be safe
to be safe
to guard his heart because if anybody
ever hurts Jamal it's gonna deal with
all this so um no to be safe and if Joel
and I have talked about this Jamal and I
have talked about this about like being
in a relationship like if he was in one
similar I get asked this a lot too and I
would always support Jamal regardless of
whatever decision he decides to make
about his personal life I would always
be there I'm always going to have his
back you know but I would tell him
that's just to always do your research
first don't believe everything a woman
tells you and just be happy you have to
be happy you have to make you you're in
your heart you have to be happy yeah
yeah all right well what can you tease
what's what's in store
we get a glimpse of this new woman have
you seen her the the new potential wise
no okay
what
what can you teach her
yeah so see how how are we gonna do the
second wife so she's just joking I'm
just joking
um
you know I felt like when I you know
it's such a short time I'm there you
know and I feel like like this was just
crazy to me this was this whole thing
and I was just like it was so crazy it's
just so crazy it's crazy to me I can't
say too much about it so it was crazy to
me all right anything else you want to
say before we go no I just want to say
that like
I'm really really happy for the people
that do follow me and that do encourage
me and that do see me as like a very
nice woman and that um support me I have
I honestly have the best followers I
swear I do and I love my little my
moderators my little attack dogs that's
what I call it but I became really close
with um like people you never thought
would be your friends or my friends now
and I'm really blessed for that
experience and I just wanted everybody
to wish me luck just pray pray and wish
me luck
[Music]
foreign